welcome to this video playing against
the National masta Killa chess killer
chess shaking here conoces okay let's
see what is doing we got an ID often
okay yeah there are so many lines in the
night of hard to tell them apart okay
maybe if I can play this I should Queen
d3m probably is preparing lon casler
zone okay it's not preparing long
cancels here I can also play Bishop to
c4 I'm not sure that it is doing me much
good but I could okay let's let's go
here now I can take with both pieces but
Knight takes ed I don't have f5 this is
a positive feature of this Queen on d3
you see Steve threatening to play a five
if I don't think so sorry I think so I
think so this is why I play five myself
but I have some some doubts here i'm not
a big expert on this but this looks like
a fairly good to version of the
structure for wine
it can arise them in the night off from
various lines the structure with the
pawn transferred to to d5 and here now
this is this a problem now but at least
he needs to take with the poor now Queen
takes Knight e5 cannot be a recommended
i would like really much to get the
bishop traded on your seven maybe i can
get this in Bishop g5 and then maybe
night a 65 okay is preventing that
hmm yeah I'm not sure maybe not a 65 but
he said he's always has Bishop b5 using
the weekend light squares it's not a
very comfortable position it really
isn't
okay at least this is at least a quite
favorable exchange him that I get this
off the board and this night be three
threatened at the moment okay can i
maybe play night if for I at Bishop c6
is really blow the kind of will move ok
this is at least has 93 against bishop
c6 playing on a booster move base here
here here we see that in Chester small
small things can mean much if somehow
the dark squared Bishop would be traded
blank would be instantly fine maybe even
better but with bishops on hmm it looks
very young and very tricky to play yeah
but it's not bow gathers I didn't expect
at all and snow my my bishop here gets
activated tremendously
hmm interesting
yeah I don't have root yet this is
really a big big point if i go here 94
why is why is he putting the the Queen
really with Quincy five coming and stuff
I don't know right so let's see I Scott
Bishop e3 okay okay i just stopped yeah
just drop back it's not a big problem
hmm i'd love to get the dark squared
Bishop exchange but I don't really see
how
yeah is something like g6 and Bishop g5
them maybe maybe h6 is not so bad anyway
getting some room here for them for the
rook now Bishop g5 that's not Queen g
three years infectable okay I'm going to
play that make sure that I get this
traded at least I have a very nice
active night now with Quincy five coming
no no that's not easy to play I'm even
threatening rookie ATM because Bishop
takes this route be one so in fact quite
tricky now
still rocky eight maybe I this rock d3
can just take on d3 Queen D for this
route d 1 ok time morning yeah yeah I am
ok ok I don't have I don't have time to
really figure it out I don't think
that's so so bad though trying to go to
e7
Brooks is have 96 something like that I
don't I don't know right so it's very
tricky to play yeah I forgot about the
c5 break really check check
it was a bit of a shame I really thought
I was back in the game again check check
check black for this one time I think I
was back in the game running around here
I'm not worse at all but I couldn't I
couldn't really find the right way to
play this is interesting in fact because
of the chances on the dark squares but
it it never really was enough i believe
maybe maybe I missed something yeah rook
b5 the computer gives us as equal I had
thought about it because of Quincy for
always this looked like some chances but
I couldn't calculate it it was
interesting yeah the computer gives us
as equal but is that's not realistic i
mean i cannot i cannot cannot play this
this is in fact even good for black no
that's interesting but okay that's not
not really realistic i'm not as i saw
this but i couldn't calculate it mmm and
now we are now i just need to take him
this is easy to see but not for me i
didn't see it so this was played and i
only had two said yeah now to to get to
the to e7 1993 wins okay
yeah I missed many moosian and when I
was pretty sure about that but I didn't
I simply didn't didn't play well yeah
here the problem is I cannot keep the c5
blockade if I magically could might
transform one night to see 5 i'm perfect
but i cannot i cannot keep the blockade
and i don't think he lets something slip
after that check yeah g5 is a bit rehab
and it's lost its losses and loss is a
loss so yeah I missed many chances here
but generally speaking I found effort to
be a very strange decision because
without it widest is better after that
white is of course not better but i
didn't i didn't really play it well
maybe yeah maybe f5 f5 mmm he's right
he's writing probably i should have
played kh1 yeah maybe it's very often a
good a good idea and this in this type
of structure making sure that nothing
terrible is happening on the diagonal
yeah well I had some chances but it was
it was tough to play i didn't manage ok
thanks for watching